so the recall effort over governor
newsom in california hitting a major
milestone organizers now claiming they
have gathered
more than 1.5 million signatures that
are needed by the way 1.5 is the marker
you need to get to
to trigger a special election more than
500 california wildfires
new encampments have been popping up
throughout l.a in the last five months
the number of people living outside
appears to have multiplied
there are now thousands of crimes a year
like this one
in which the suspects are homeless one
in six
restaurants will not survive the
pandemic people are just bailing there's
a mass exodus out of california right
now
you can quibble about the guidelines et
cetera et cetera but the spirit
of what i'm preaching all the time was
contradicted
today we're going to talk about why
governor gavin newsom in california is
being recalled we're going to talk about
how the recall works
we're going to talk about why people in
california are angry at gavin newsom
we're going to talk about his coveted
policy and the failures
of his covet policy first let me just
say thank you to our friends over at
raycon for sponsoring this video
let me first explain how recall works in
the state of california the way that it
works is 12 percent
of the last voting population that
number of people have to sign
a recall petition in order to get a
recall on the ballot
so that would mean about 1.5 million
people would need to sign
a recall petition in order to get his
recall on the ballot then when the
recall actually happens
there are two questions that you vote on
the first question is should the
governor be recalled you require over 50
of the people voting to say that he
should be recalled and then you have the
recall election which doesn't include
news um it includes a bunch of other
candidates so the last time this
happened back in 2003 gray davis got
recalled arnold schwarzenegger became
the governor
because the ballot was split one
thousand ways right a majority of
californians agreed that gray davis
should not remain governor
but then there were one million
candidates who ran including people like
gary coleman famously ran there were
porn stars who ran
as well and arnold schwarzenegger
emerged the governor of california
at 48 in the polls well this time around
just in terms of pure likelihood that
newsome will be recalled
the current polls show that there's not
a majority of californians who are
willing to
actually vote gavin newsom out of office
so you can get
the recall on the ballot but it looks
like that first question right now will
fail now
the recall election is not going to take
place for several months the recall
election
is going to take place presumably a lot
later this year when that happens that
means months and months of negative
campaigning about gavin newsom and there
is a lot to base that negative
campaigning on because gavin newsom is a
trash heap of a governor he's a terrible
governor he pledged that he was in some
ways going to be more moderate than
jerry brown
gavin newsom has presided over a massive
loss of business
hundreds of thousands of people have
left california because of the business
climate in california he has pressed
forward
with plans for higher taxation his press
forward with higher regulation
the cities have been made cesspools of
homelessness
the living conditions have declined
radically in places like san francisco
and los angeles a bifurcated stratified
society has emerged
in places like san francisco and los
angeles where basically if you're very
rich you can live there and if you're
very poor you're homeless that's
essentially what has happened there that
is due to a wide variety of state and
local programs plus
it also turns out that the crime rates
in california have been rising
they rose precipitously last year in the
wake of the black lives matter protests
which were supported of course
by gavin newsom policing in places like
los angeles went completely
down the toilet again because the state
decided not to support its police
officers
so you got a bad business climate got a
bad tax climate got a bad regulatory
climate you have a terrible climate
with regard to crime you have a terrible
climate with regard to immigration
because there are sanctuary cities all
over the state of
california and california makes every
attempt not to
have new immigrants to the state of
california assimilate in any serious way
to other sort of traditional american
ideals it's just not something
california's particularly interested in
you've seen net outflows from california
many years in a row
and that's been exacerbated by newsome
okay you add on top of that the fact
that gavin newsom has been a horror show
when it comes to coven
and that's the recipe for a recall so
gavin newsom has been
pretty much a waste of space but i will
tell you something that is not a waste
of space in fact something that will
make your life
infinitely better i'm talking of course
about these raycons
raycon is disrupting the electronics
industry by designing premium wireless
audio for half the price without
compromise
raycon prioritizes their customer
experience from start to finish
raycon offers their wireless earbuds in
a range of fun colors and patterns
a variety of fit options no dangling
wires no stems plus
raycon has a 45 day free return policy
so what exactly do you have to lose
raycon's are great they give you six
hours of playtime seamless bluetooth
pairing more bass more compact design
for a comfortable
noise isolating fit so if you're trying
to take a break from screens but you
don't want to feel totally unplugged
raycon wireless earbuds those are the
best way to bring your favorite content
with you
wherever you go some of these brands you
know they're kind of one size fits all
not so with these babies
not with these raycons you can see right
here personalize the fit so they fit
into my ear absolutely
absolutely perfectly like a glove check
that out oh my god
look magnificent so click the link in
the description box or go to
buyrecon.com
shapiro yt and get 15 off your raycon
purchase
so this effort to recall gavin newsom
actually started last year
it picked up a little bit of steam but
not tremendous amounts of steam and then
the coveted pandemic hit and at the very
beginning the media loved avenues he was
the best he was incredible he pursued
lockdowns
at the highest level people in los
angeles i was living there
were locked down for months at a time
they are still locked down and lockdown
is the preferred policy of gavin newsom
there is only one problem
lockdown resulted in economic
catastrophe the unemployment rate in the
state of california is nine percent
right now the deaths per million rate is
very very similar to that of the state
of florida where i currently
reside the difference is florida didn't
close it was very funny so i headlined
the other day it said
california and florida took exactly
opposite tax on the pandemic and ended
up with the same result
well they ended up very nearly with the
same result in terms of deaths per
million there are a few
notable differences one florida is the
second oldest state in america
california is the fifth youngest state
in america so
what you would expect is florida to have
a lot more death than california because
coveted predominantly kills people over
the age of 65.
but if your death's per million rate is
the same as california's and your state
is much older
this means you have outperformed
expectations it means gavin newsom has
underperformed expectations
if it turns out that all the policies
that you pursued not only ended with the
same death rate as florida but also
ended with a far higher unemployment
rate nine percent compared to 6.1
percent in florida
and schools being closed across the
spectrum as opposed to being open
in florida this means that ron desantis
and florida did an excellent job
and gavin newsom did a horrible job and
most people in california know this
there is a reason that major companies
have left it's a reason that larry
ellison founder of oracle is out
there's a reason that the founder of
palantir is out there's a reason joe
rogan
is out there's reason elon musk is out
there's a reason that we
took our 100 jobs out of california and
we left so what should gavin newsom do
if he doesn't actually want to be
recalled well
maybe he should end the lockdowns the
fact is that lockdown policy in
california has been a complete
non-success so
why doesn't he think about allowing more
people to reopen their businesses why
doesn't he make it clear to californians
that he wants them to reopen their
businesses
asap why not just start talking about
refunding the police as opposed to
defunding the police it turns out that a
lot of the poll data from
2020 show that donald trump's gains in
the black and hispanic community came
largely
because of the defund the police
movement that people like avenues have
been backing
the lifestyle in california has declined
rapidly because of lack of police why
doesn't gavin newsom
make alliances with the lapd's union why
doesn't he talk to the san francisco
police union and talk about cleaning up
the streets which brings us to criminal
policy
why exactly doesn't gavin newsom push
for the funding of new mental health
facilities and a change in the law
so that people who actually have serious
mental illness can
be more easily taken off the streets
where they are living in their own filth
and put in a facility where they can
actually be taken care of the fact is
that homelessness is a preventable
problem but gavin newsom has done
absolutely nothing to fix it if he
actually doesn't want businesses fleeing
from the state and taking along the jobs
one thing he could talk about with his
fellows in the democratic-run
legislature
is actually lowering taxes rather than
increasing taxes in the state of
california he could actually fight back
against the teachers unions
he could fight back against the public
sector unions because guess what he's
the governor he's a democrat the unions
aren't going to go support republicans
in response so unless he thinks that he
is super vulnerable on his left flank
which is really unlikely at this point
then why wouldn't he just
speak a little truth to power inside of
his own caucus democrats in california
never seem to be able to tell
the most ardent members of their own
base that they need to hold off and that
is something that gavin newsom actually
used to do
i remember i interviewed gavin newsom
personally back when i was on la radio
on local
and he said that the high-speed bullet
train was a bad idea if you had your
brothers would you kill the thing
i would take the dollars and redirect it
to other more pressing infrastructure
needs
then of course he got into power and it
was ah this high-speed bullet train what
a wonderful idea
it is fairly obvious what kind of
policies need to be embraced in order
for california to become
a better place to live gavin newsom
could do all of these and by the way he
could get away with it because it's a
one-party state and he's the governor
and he's a democrat he's not doing any
of that stuff because he's so
afraid of his own base that he's
unwilling to tell them things that are
absolutely true and that need to be said
to make life better for all californians
i mean if you want to look at a governor
who's doing well how about my new
governor governor desantis
actually left it to localities to decide
exactly how to deal with coveted which
makes sense because people live in their
local communities
we will never do any of these lockdowns
again governor desantis suggested that
you'd actually have to have an excuse
not to reopen your schools at a
percentage of the population
that that's a good thing he was actually
encouraging freedom governor desantis
has stood strong against the increase of
taxes in the state of florida governor
desantis has stood very much in favor
of the police he has stood against crime
all these are things that have made
governor destances very popular in a 50
50 state
governor gavin newsom isn't even
supremely popular in california which is
like a 70 30 state at this point
now here's the reality as i said earlier
i doubt that there are the votes there
to actually recall gavin newsom
even if gavin newsom were recalled it
would take a splitting of the vote in
order for a republican to become a
governor
of california but it is a sign that the
democrats
who are widespread in california
basically about 45
of registered voters in california are
democrats about 25
24 25 are registered republicans another
are registered no party it turns out
that the democrat and independent voters
they are frustrated with the governance
they just haven't figured out the
solution which is not to elect people
like this anymore
when they finally figure that out maybe
there will be hope for the state of
california